pékin fin du mois d'avril quartier des
ambassades
le petit paris un des restaurants
fréquentés par les occidentaux vient de
perdre une partie de son nom est la
référence à la france a presque disparu
en ce moment notre enseigne est en
réparation on a un petit problème
technique
problèmes techniques pour le serveur
mais d'autres y voient une mesure de
représailles contre la france
car depuis trois semaines les chinois
sont en colère
une poussée de fièvre patriotique qui a
pris pour cible les magasins carrefour
un symbole de la présence française
[Applaudissements]
la police est là et tolèrent ces
rassemblements pourtant habituellement
interdits en chine une dizaine de
grandes villes ont été touchées
la chaîne d'hypermarchés française est
accusée par la rumeur de finances est
l'ennemi juré du régime chinois le dalaï
lama le chef spirituel des tibétains
le chinois on doit tous s'unir on veut
empêcher les gens d'entrer dans le
magasin
ce qu'on fait est utile les clients de
carrefour sont très peu nombreux
aujourd'hui
une hostilité à l'égard de la france qui
inquiète les 25000 expatriés qui vivent
en chine
à pékin devant le lycée français nous
retrouvons nicolas et martin
élève en terminale ils vivent ici depuis
plusieurs années avec leurs parents et
n'ont jamais connu un tel climat
l'ambiance a changé un peu il ya
quelques jours c'était assez tendu et
puis même je me rappelle de
vendredi dernier on avoue on a recevait
des sms
comme quoi il serait dangereux de sortir
donc on avait un peu carrément peur
d'aller dehors
un début de psychose en partie liée à la
mésaventure qui est arrivée à ces deux
adolescents dans ce bar le 4 avril au
soir
[Applaudissements]
les deux lycéens ont été pris dans une
descente anti drogue menée par la police
chinoise
toute l'opération a été filmée et
diffusée sur la télévision publique une
belle mise en scène pour montrer le
grand nettoyage qui s'opère avant les
jeux ben c'est musclé comme c'est arrivé
c'est assez impressionnant en fait parce
qu'ils avaient les bras fusil à pompe
c'est lé soit et où donc bon patron des
jeunes c'est un peu peur douar simple
pourquoi on était dans ce bar la
bouder on était dans les dents les
malchanceux et voilà ces t-shirts sur la
tête on trouve dans le camion et puis
comme ça
des malades mais on a calé des sacs sur
la tête les sags il sac en plastique sur
la tête et je postais pour humilier ou
repas convoi femmes enceintes
[Applaudissements]
six élèves du lycée français se font
embarquer parmi la vingtaine de
personnes interpellées contrôlé positif
au cannabis martin passera 15 jours en
détention nicolas lui est resté deux
jours au commissariat
nous simples débattu en fera peut-être
panier et non de me faire un constat
chez sos
l'hôpital international et donc ouais
j'avais pas mal de petits coups quand ça
s'est passé maintenant mais
moi j'aurais pris part à la
plus ennuyeux martin va devoir écourter
la durée de son séjour en chine
j'avais un visage qui durera jusqu'en
juillet et donc quand j'ai quand
maintenant il s'arrête le 30 avril donc
c'est juste une façon polie de me dire
de dégager
je suis obligé de partir c'est un peu
embêtant quelques mois avant le bac mais
mais rien à faire pour dépasser la
nationalité de nicolas et martin at elle
quelque chose à voir avec leur
arrestation difficile à dire mais trois
jours plus tard l'hostilité à l'égard de
la france va monter d'un cran
le 7 avril la flamme olympique traverse
paris des centaines de manifestants pro
tibétains décide de gâcher la fête
[Musique]
dans la mêlée jin jing une athlète
chinoise handicapés et bousculé de cette
journée c'est l'image que retiendront
les chinois ce qu'il considère comme une
agression les scandalisent
[Applaudissements]
la jeune femme devient l'héroïne de tout
un peuple et l'incident viraux coup de
froid diplomatique
[Musique]
des émissaires français de haut rang
sont dépêchés auprès des dirigeants
chinois pour désamorcer la crise
jean pierre raffarin les aussi christian
poncelet
il y a deux semaines le président du
sénat vient même présenté ses excuses au
nom du président de la république à la
jeune athlète handicapé
ce qui s'est produit à paris le 7 avril
ange entrer dans votre pays de la mairie
je tiens à vous assurer que les
incidents de cette triste journée
provoqué par quelques-uns ne reflète pas
les sentiments de mes concitoyens pour
le peuple chinois
le gouvernement chinois appellent à la
modération
pourtant ces derniers jours la polémique
n'est pas retombée à pékin les clients
des hypermarchés carrefour continue à
penser que l'enseigne soutient les
tibétains
si c'est vrai qu'ils sont soutenus le
dalaï lama alors c'est illégal
c'est contre la politique chinoise
alors gelé boycotterait
pour la chine il faut le faire
carrefour qui transcrit en chinois veut
dire famille joie et bonheur ouvre deux
magasins par mois dans le pays ici on
vend même des poissons vivants tout est
ajustée aux habitudes locales
mais depuis le début de la crise la
direction refuse de s'exprimer nous
filmé en caméra cachée en ce jour de
semaine les allées sont loin d'être
déserte pourtant les clients continuent
de recevoir de mystérieux messages sur
leur téléphone qui ciblent des enseignes
occidentales
ces deux jeunes filles acceptent de le
montrer à notre traducteur mais pas aux
journalistes français
je peux voir patois d'accord
sur les téléphones sur google sur
internet vous pouvez trouver ce genre de
message le message dit le 1er mai de
boycotter les magasins carrefour et
wal-mart et le 1er juin les restaurants
kentucky fried chicken
comment dire c'est une manière pour nous
d'exprimer nos sentiments vers la france
par rapport aux menaces de boycott des
jeux olympiques nous attendons aussi des
excuses de la part du président français
pour les chinois les critiques sur le
tibet sont inacceptables à leurs yeux
cette province fait partie intégrante de
leur territoire
cette chanson par exemple est à la
gloire du nouveau train qui relie pékin
à lhassa au tibet
des chansons des sms mais la riposte
chinoise se fait aujourd'hui plus
virulente
et c'est bien la france qui se retrouve
dans le collimateur
ang lee kun anime l'union des patriotes
chinois son site internet diffuse et
relayent des messages nationaliste le
ton reste cordial mais le propos est
ferme
regardez regardez
je vous avais dit que le phénomène n'est
pas en se réduisant
regardez regardez c'est ce que je disais
et ça c'est juste les commentaires
tombée aujourd'hui il y en a déjà plus
de 3000 euros à près de 100% de ses
commentaires vont dans le même sens il
s'oppose à la france boycottez carrefour
ça va ça c'est pas grave
français sale porc sage accepte ou pas
déclenché la guerre se battre se battre
pourquoi dingue d'en arriver là
l'ong a manifesté devant l'union
européenne à pékin pour lui ce sont
l'honneur et la fierté des chinois qui
sont en jeu dans cette affaire
les manifestations sur le parcours de la
flamme nous avons vu cela comme une
agression une provocation contre les
jeux olympiques mais aussi contre la
chine et contre tout le peuple chinois
donc nous nous devions de contre
attaquer
est ce que vous allez boycotter vous
même
j'ai moi même utiliser ce matin encore
des produits français
c'était des produits de beauté
plus surprenant alors qu'ils pourraient
d'en subir les conséquences
la plupart des français qui vivent ici
comprennent le coup de sort des chinois
j'ai pas le drapeau français sur la
voiture donc ça devrait pas poser de
problème
alexandre ahmed s'est installé à pékin
il ya quatre ans depuis son arrivée il a
constaté les énormes sacrifices
consentis par les chinois pour préparer
les jeux
ça c'est la nouvelle chine et les
chinois qui viennent l'admirer
il ya tellement d'efforts qui ont été
faits pour que pour que tout ça sorte de
terre pour l'obtention des jeux
olympiques toutes les promesses qui ont
été faites qu'aujourd'hui ils veulent
une fête parfaite et il essaie de ne pas
ternir sa part soit des événements qui
pourraient avoir à pékin squad et
des choses qui pourrait obscurcir le
tableau
à pékin la société que dirige alexandre
fabrique et vend des peintures de luxe
since i want you to ghana tor il
travaille avec des clients et des
salariés chinois bohanne son bras droit
a vécu en france
tabac le temps one ne répondra pas comme
beaucoup de ses compatriotes il évite
les sujets qui fâchent ils préfèrent
nous montrer sur son ordinateur les
petits coeurs patriotique qui ponctuent
désormais tous les échanges sur internet
en chine
pour les chinois
surtout cette année l'année 2010
c'est une preuve très très chaud en
quatre ans de présence à pékin alexandre
a vu le pays change et une évolution pas
forcément perçu depuis la france pour
lui l'occident n'a pas de leçon à donner
vouloir calquer notre vision des droits
de l'homme dans un pays comme la chine
qui fait vingt fois la taille de la
france qui a une population d'1 milliard
et demi de personnes c'est pas possible
c'est pas possible de de juger à l'aune
de nos concepts ce qui se passe dans un
pays où le salaire moyen est inférieur à
100 euros c'est
donc on peut faire des choses un niveau
individuel mais je pense que vouloir les
prendre de face
comme ils ont eu l'impression que ça
s'est passé depuis deux semaines c'est
c'est faire preuve et d'une da
compréhension de leur culture et ces
faits et ces essais pas être à l'écouté
de tout ce qui se passe pas être à
l'écouté de tout ce qui se passe depuis
30 ans dans le pays où les gens essayent
de faire voyager les gens essayent de
faire changer les choses
un grand malentendu presque un sentiment
de trahison pour les chinois car
jusque-là vue de pékin la france était
un pays ami
en grande banlieue de la capitale nous
avons rencontré liu fang c'est un de ces
nombreux amoureux déçu
personnellement au départ j'avais une
très bonne impression de la france
la france et la chine ont une longue
histoire commune
riche dans les années 60 la france avait
été le premier pays occidental à
reconnaître la chine communiste comme
tant d'autres liu fang avait cru à une
relation privilégiée
à ses yeux la brouille va laisser des
traces
même après les jeux olympiques sont je
pense que les relations franco chinoises
vont pâtir de tout ça
on va garder un souvenir triste la
france était notre ami
et lorsque tu es trahi par un ami ça
fait encore plus mal que par quelqu'un
que tu ne connais pas
vous savez beaucoup de chinois
connaissent l'hymne national français la
marseillaise
ou la fredonner si vous
[Musique]
il y a trois mois encore aucun français
de chine n'aurait imaginé une telle
crise sûrement pas igor darbo consultant
ici depuis trois ans il avait misé sur
les jeux pour lancer la carrière
musicale de son fils arman à 6 ans et
enregistre son premier disque
[Musique]
il chante un monde un rêve en chinois en
anglais et en français c'est le slogan
des jeux
[Musique]
moi je n'ai pas lâché pas le sentiment
de faire la propagande nous on est pris
dans cette controverse qui ne dépasse
totalement j'espère simplement que
[Musique]
que ça pourra éventuellement
entrer dans le cadre d'un apaisement des
tensions entre les deux pays
[Musique]
apaiser les tensions entre les deux pays
peut-être
en tout cas pour l'instant chanter en
français à pékin ce n'est sûrement pas
le meilleur argument de vente
[Musique]
jamais
toi
aussi